it's not okay I woke up this morning
feeling excited and frustrated I was
excited because this is becoming a
movement and and I've talked about it
being a movement and the start was just
me talking about it me in front of a
camera me and my computer me by myself
just talking about it believing and
talking about it and now it's happening
it's happening people are hashtag and
believe people are writing into me on
youtube every to every video i put up
gets comments every tweet i put out
people retweeted they respond to me i
get emails every single day from people
saying that I've helped change their
lives I've help restructure their
thinking Oh guys I mean so much to me
and it's such a it's a big confidence
boost because it's not just me talking
to myself anymore there's an audience
there's a movement this thing is
building this thing is real it's
tangible and every time you guys comment
and like and tweet and write to me it
just adds more fuel it makes you want to
do more makes me feel like this is
working that excites me that's what I
woke up excited about i also woke up
frustrated i was frustrated because i
looked at one of my videos from a couple
weeks ago and it needs to be better the
video needs to be better and I look at
how I was three months ago and it's
already way better every week I do i do
this on wednesday every week every week
it gets better i get better i feel i get
better at least i hope you guys think
i'm getting better the videos are
getting better i'm getting better on
camera the quality is getting better but
it still needs to be better for this
movement to really be powerful for this
move with a hit a billion entrepreneurs
this needs to be better i need to be
better on camera and i was talking to a
friend of mine today and it was
explaining i'm really excited I'm really
happy like this is taking off this is
this is going to be unstoppable but for
it to propel more I need to be better
faster I'm getting better but has to be
getting better faster and she
she said hey don't get down on yourself
like you're doing a good job it's okay
you're going this thing is growing your
your don't be so hard on yourself and
I'm not down on myself and I know that
what I'm making is good it's really good
hope you hopefully you guys if you're
still watching this video now it's
because you think they're pretty good I
know they're good I'm not worried about
that I'm not a downer but I have a
limited amount of time in this life to
have a huge impact and I want it to
happen so I don't want good enough
videos I don't want really really good
beaters I want amazing videos and you
should want that too because as soon as
you start settling as soon as you start
thinking oh this is good enough row yeah
yeah I'm making really good progress you
stop pushing yourself you stop forcing
yourself to get better and you end up
settling you settle for mediocre you
settle for an average life you settle
for average and so most people do and
it's funny how this is our default
reaction if somebody comes to you and
they're struggling with something to say
I really hate my job I hate my boss I
don't like going there anymore I'm at my
wit's end what do you usually say you
usually try to comfort somebody you tell
them oh it's you know hang in there it's
going to be okay you know get through
the holiday season whatever it is you
give them we want to we want to
alleviate their pain we want to
alleviate their short-term pain and so
we give them something to make them feel
better like a little drug to make them
feel better but you're not helping them
your job as a friend isn't just to
console them to make them feel better in
the moment you're supposed to give them
advice to help the long term help them
think bigger help them live a happy life
if this job is not right for them they
should leave that job and go do
something else and that's going to cause
even more pain short term a lot more
uncertainty a lot more questions how do
I pay my bills how do I support myself
where do i go find this job do i start
my own business what do i do you're
creating even more pain doubt
uncertainty than what they came to you
with but that's what they need my job
here to help you isn't to tell you what
you want to hear it's not to tell you
that everything is great and you're
going to be
fine is to tell you what you need to
hear is to give you the advice that you
need to grow your business and often
that's going to mean you changing your
beliefs about something you stretching
yourself beyond what you've been able to
do before you challenging yourself to
become a new person to become a better
version of you because that's what's
needed to really have an impact and I'm
telling you these things and it's going
to be painful for you and you have a
choice to either accept that and to do
something about it or say every doesn't
know what he's talking about or that's
too hard and you keep living your
mediocre life I love feedback when I
when I create something I don't want
people telling me how good it is I want
them telling me what needs to be better
how it can have a more a greater impact
I don't take things personally I want to
hear the negative stuff help me get
better as you get more successful you
don't want to surround yourself with
yes-men we just tell you great great
great yes yes yes you need people that
challenge you to push you so it's not
okay you want to be average then that's
ok you want to be great it's not okay
you got to get better so my videos have
to get better this video has to get
better this video me in a year is going
to be way better I know that I just
wanted to be faster so I'm doing
everything I can I practice I hustle I
put everything into making these things
for you guys and it's going to keep
getting better and I'm open to your
feedback so do me a favor okay two
things important stuff one if you're
struggling with something if you're
upset about the quality of something if
you are having if you have standards
with your business don't settle don't
settle for crappy standards for
something that's average it okay push
yourself push yourself beyond what
anybody else is going to push you to do
beyond what your friends and family and
your people in your network will tell
you to do have higher standards for
yourself have greater expectations that
anybody has for you have greater
expectations for yourself believe in
yourself more than anybody else does and
two when somebody comes to you with a
problem and you know you can help them
and you see something greater for them
you
wit to them to tell them the truth to
tell them what they need to hear not
what they want to hear be a good friend
be a good mentor be a good person and
even though it's going to cause more
pain short term if that's what you
really believe they need you owe it to
them to let them know your homework for
this week believe those are you watching
like the video please give it a thumbs
up below I love sinos come in and let me
know what you think give me some
feedback good or bad make these videos
better leave it below tell me what you
think you have a suggestion let me know
you have a question for your business
put it below I'll make a video response
I love you guys I make these videos for
you so I want to hear from you thank you
so much and I'll see you soon